[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire
l ex n 9 elle n'y est revenu en russie
le 17 janvier après cinq mois de
convalescence à l'étranger pour un
empoisonnement dont il accuse bladimir
poutine et les services de renseignement
russes d'être responsable il a été
arrêté depuis des manifestations lieu
dans plus d'une centaine de villes pour
réclamer sa libération
manifestations auxquelles il a appelé
avant son incarcération en même temps
qu'il a posté sur youtube une vidéo dans
laquelle il accuse la dîmière poutine de
s'être fait construire une demeure d'un
milliard d'euros sur la mer noire
les autorités russes de leur côté réfute
les accusations d'empoisonnement et de
corruption et qualifie alexeï navalni et
ses partisans d' escroc alors que se
passe-t-il en russie pour en débattre
nous avons invité frédéric pons qui est
journaliste notamment pour la revue de
géopolitique conflit vous avez été
président de l'association des
journalistes de défense avant de devenir
le président d'honneur vous êtes
d'ailleurs colonel de réserve dans les
parachutistes des troupes de marine et
vous êtes l'auteur de poutine
une biographie publiée chez calmann lévy
pour vous frédéric pons qu'est ce qui se
passe en se ruant russie en ce moment
alors pour aller très vite
il s'agit d'une péripétie politique une
nouvelle péripétie politique embêtante
pour vladimir poutine et le pouvoir dans
la perspective d'élections législatives
cette année que et cette péripétie
gelard situe dans un cadre plus global
avec une nouvelle offensive de
l'occident pour déstabiliser ou
diabolisées vladimir poutine avec deux
deux dossiers majeurs dont on reparlera
le dossier nord stream le gazoduc europe
russo européen
et puis les autres dossiers l'ukraine et
la syrie et l'iran jean radvanyi vous
êtes géographe professeur émérite de
géographie de la russie l inalco
l'institut des langues et civilisations
orientales avait été également le
directeur du centre franco russe de
recherches en sciences humaines et
sociales de moscou de 2008 à 2012
d'ailleurs l'auteur de retour d'une
autre russie une plongée dans le pays de
poutine aux éditions du bord de l'eau et
de la russie entre peur et défis qu
écrit
avec marlène la ruelle chez armand colin
même question comment analysez vous ce
qui se passe en russie en ce moment pour
moi ce n'était pas tout à fait une
péripétie je pense qu'il s'agit d'une
nouvelle phase dans la politique russe
qui n'aura pas de conséquences
dramatiques je ne pense pas que monsieur
poutine soit renversé mais pour la
première fois il ya un vrai opposant que
tout le monde connaît en russie même si
tout le monde ne le soutient pas loin de
là qui a bien sûr le soutien de
l'occident mais qui révèle toute une
série de fractures et de problèmes
fondamentaux de la société russe de
l'économie russe de la politique de
vladimir poutine et de son gouvernement
et qui va avoir des conséquences à long
terme même si monsieur navalni reste en
prison et même si il est clair qu'ils ne
sera pas dans les échéances électorales
à venir en septembre 2021
parce que jamais on ne le laissera ni
lui ni ses proches être candidat mais
c'est une mauvaise solution
arnaud dubien vous vous avez été
chercheur sur la russie à l'iris
l'institut de relations internationales
et stratégiques vous avez ensuite dirigé
l'édition russe de la revue foreign
policy et les lettres confidentielles
russie à intelligence et ukraine
intelligence vous avez été consultant
sur la russie pour le ministère de la
défense ou pour le ministère des
affaires étrangères pour le parlement
européen où pour de grands groupes
industriels aujourd'hui vous dirigez
l'observatoire franco russe depuis 2012
date de sa création par le conseil
économique de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie franco russe votre dernier
rapport a été publié fin 2010 9
pour vous qu'est ce qui se passe
actuellement en russie on voit un
mouvement de contestation significative
fois que pas inédit sous la présidence
de vladimir poutine puisqu'il ya eu des
manifestations plus importantes fin 2011
début 2012
par exemple ce qui se passe est
important parce que cela a été dit il y
a des échéances électorales cette année
des législatives en septembre puis il y
à un processus de transition une
succession théoriquement à 2024
peut-être après en tout cas c'est un
sujet qui perturbe les élites russes et
qui est présent à l'esprit de l'ensemble
des responsables à moscou donc on n'est
certainement pas la veille d'une
révolution je crois comme l'a dit jean
radvanyi que alexeï navalni n'a
évidemment aucune chance d'accéder au
pouvoir pas seulement parce qu'il est
empêché parce qu'il n'incarne pas
aujourd'hui une alternative crédible à
vladimir poutine il ne bénéficie pas du
soutien d'un soutien majoritaire au sein
de la population mais effectivement
c'est un facteur de turbulences qui
révèle des choses et qui pourrait être
utilisé par d'autres acteurs dans ce
contexte politique
alors pour tous ceux qui nous regardent
en ce moment et qui se dirait que tu
pourrait se dire tiens pourquoi ya pas
un tel pourquoi n'ont ils pas inviter
une tel ou un tel
qu'il sache que nous avons invité
beaucoup de monde particulièrement chez
ce que rappelle les anti poutine et et
qui la plupart évidemment ont refusé
notre avis thatcher je dis évidemment
mais ça n'avait rien d'évident
m'enfin on s'y attendait un peu ils ont
refusé voilà donc le débat maintenant
commence vous venez de dire arnaud
dubien que c'était pas les plus grandes
manifestations que d'autres étaient plus
importantes en 2011
c'est pourtant ce qu'ont dit que ce
serait les plus importantes
manifestations non autorisées en russie
depuis les 20 dernières années donc
depuis grosso modo l'arrivée au pouvoir
de vladimir poutine ça n'est pas le cas
d'après vous non il ya eu des
manifestations fin 2011 début 2012 pour
contester les résultats des élections
législatives
c'était assez différent ces
manifestations dans le sens où il était
essentiellement moscovite
ils ont réuni jusqu'à 100 mille cent
vingt mille personnes
ce que l'on voit ces derniers jours hier
et le
3 janvier c'est quelque chose d'un peu
différent des manifestations qui sont
mieux répartis à l'échelle du pays y
compris dans des villes réputées plutôt
tranquille on voit une nouvelle
génération de manifestants beaucoup de
primo manifestement des gens parfois la
culture politique assez éloigné de ce
qu'on qualifie de d'intelligence sa
traditionnelle donc c'est un phénomène
assez intéressant nouveau mais qui dans
son ampleur n'est pas forcément inédit
alors les partisans de banny parle de
250 à 300 mille manifestants dans tout
le pays
qu'est ce que vous en pensez jean
radvanyi france assez difficile de
comptabiliser comme d'habitude il ya là
les les comptabilités de la 2d des
forces de l'ordre et les comptabilités
de ceux qui qui invite à ces
manifestations
ce qui est sûr je reprends le propos
d'arnaud du bien c'est que il ya des
manifestations dans le pratique mans
toutes les grandes villes de tout le
pays depuis la frontière occidentale
jusqu en extrême orient jusqu'à
vladivostok y compris dans des régions
où jusqu'à présent il n'y avait
pratiquement jamais de manifestants des
régions qui sont qu'ils votent à 70 à
80% pour vladimir poutine où son parti
dans toutes les élections
ce qui est frappant aussi cesser les
jeunes le et c'est très important ça on
va sans doute en reparler parce que les
jeunes ils n'ont pas les mêmes sources
d'information ils regardent pas la
télévision
ils s'informent sur internet sur les
réseaux sociaux et ils sont semble-t-il
enfin on sait que ses traditionnels ils
sont plus critiques
mais on sait qu'il ya eu des sondages
ils avaient voté pour la 10 meilleures
poutines les lie à un décrochage
il ya un décrochage il sera intéressant
d'analyser sans doute que la
personnalité de navalni indépendamment
du fait qu'il est il n'est pas très
populaire mais sa personnalité d'homme
très active très bas tant il est jeune
il représente quelque chose de nouveau
et même s'il a pas de chance d'arriver
au pouvoir ça peut pour pour lé pour
toute une série de catégorie c voilà
c'est un élément qui a la foi et
perturbateur
révélateur et qui cristallise un ce
nombre de phénomènes nouveaux
réponse oui alors j'ai employé le terme
de péripéties parce que arnaud dubien
l'a bien précisé il ya déjà eu d'autres
manifestations au fil des années
d'opposants notamment à la suite de
l'assassinât de deux opposants
politiques ou de journalistes les gens
étaient descendus dans la rue
aujourd'hui on a un effet de loupe de
miroir grossissant sur navale dit
surtout dans les médias occidentaux on a
tendance à exagérer sans doute un peu
l'importance du phénomène qui existe un
c'est une personnalité très intéressante
navalni mais je me souviens très bien en
main en 2018 j'étais allé à moscou
j'avais rencontré beaucoup de gens de
l'entourage de navalni ses partisans
c'est les électeurs qu'il pourrait avoir
et on voyait très bien qu'il ya à la
fois un phénomène générationnel les les
gens qui aujourd'hui entre entre 15 et
30 ans n'ont connu que poutine est donc
au pouvoir et donc il ya un rejet un
rejet bien naturel de cette personnalité
qu'il voit constamment dans les médias à
la télévision ou sur les réseaux sociaux
donc il ya un rejet générationnel qui
touche une partie de la jeunesse russe
il ya aussi un phénomène sociologique
c'est que on le voit bien à travers ces
manifestations
ce sont surtout les grandes villes le
centre des grandes villes et donc c'est
une sociologie très particulière de
jeunes donc jusqu'à à peu près 35 ans de
jeunes branchés connecter un peu fasciné
par la culture occidentale par qui
souhaitent voyager qu'ils souhaitent
plus de liberté et ça c'est une réalité
beaucoup de jeunes se reconnaissent dans
la personnalité de navalni et puis y'a
un troisième facteur qui joue en sa
faveur
et là qui dépasse largement les laisser
ces secteurs sociologique ou
générationnel dont je parle c'est son
thème de combat la lutte contre la
corruption
quand on va en russie tout le monde
parle de la corruption et tout le monde
a l'impression d'être mal payé et d'être
dirigés par des gens qui volent l'argent
que ce soit des gens dans
l'administration dans la peau
l'éthique des élus et c est donc ce
thème de la corruption est très
populaire et touche tout le monde y
compris des partisans de vladimir
poutine et du pouvoir navalni a très
bien joué dans cette affaire il a mis le
doigt sur le seul élément qui peut lui a
tiré une popularité une sympathie parce
que pour le reste ça a été dit il n'a
aucun programme
il est il à il a beaucoup et ré de de la
gauche ou ou de l'extrême gauche à
l'extrême droite de l'échiquier
politique russe il n'est pas jugé
crédible comme opposants il est jugé
crédible quand il dénonce et je termine
avec ça il a été très malin parce que
jusqu'à maintenant les russes considéré
que beaucoup de gens s'enrichissent et
de façon illicite qui avait beaucoup de
corruption mais poutine on le voit dans
les sondages été relativement épargnée
et là avec site cette histoire un peu
fantasmatique du du palais du palace
attribué à poutine il le met nommément
dans la cour des plus grands corrompus
de la russie et là il peut faire mal
même si les russes décrypte tout ça
c'est bien en tout cas ce qui fait la
majorité de l'électorat russe c'est à
dire au delà des centres villes des
centres urbains et des plus jeunes
générations
justement sur ces accusations de
corruption venant ont tout de suite à
cela on a vu des images qui ont été vus
70 millions de fois sur youtube c'est la
fameuse vidéo 400 millions +60 envoyé
j'en suis resté au début par deux des
mois donc des images énormément vu alors
qu'en est il exactement offrir le pont
vous avez l'air de 2,2 de dire que les
gens ne sont pas dupes
qu'est ce que vous en pensez sera de
gagner le jeu c'est un saint c'est un
dossier compliqué d'abord parce que en
fait on en parle depuis plus de dix ans
parce que les premières photos de ce
fameux palais sont apparus il ya une
dizaine d'années déjà dans la dans
certains médias des photos de
l'intérieur achevé sert des pièces avec
des meubles avec des rideaux avec des
chaises
et donc et à l'époque déjà c'était pas
navalni c'était 7 des médias qui disait
vladimir poutine est en train de se
faire construire un palais et puis alors
navalni a repris sa dent dans son film
que quelques revues donc plus de 100
millions de personnes dont à peu près
des trois quarts des russes
et lui il a cherché à la fois les et on
savait pas on sait toujours pas à qui il
appartient c'est extraordinaire parce
que tout de suite la grâce à
l'administration présidentielle a dit
non non c'est pas vladimir poutine mais
le plus étonnant c'est qu'on sait
toujours pas à qui appartient ce château
qu'il fait construire dans des
conditions quand même assez
extraordinaire
c'est pas si c'est pas un petit palais
d'ordinaire et donc n'avait ni son
habileté ça a été de deux fouilles est
vraiment le dossier de chercher des
preuves dans les documents cadastraux
dans les échanges bancaires quand il a
pu probablement il a été aidé dans
divers par diverses sources internes ou
externes
c'est on en saura un jour les tenants et
les aboutissants mais au total même si
effectivement ce n'est pas vladimir
poutine qui a commandité ce palais il en
ressort un dossier accablant sur les
élites qui entourent vladimir poutine
sur le réseau d'amis oligarques qui l'a
créé
est ce assez navalni narbonne invente
rien parce que c'est quelque chose qu'on
connaît depuis des années il ya eu plein
d'articles là dessus sur la façon dont
il a créé un réseau de fidèles depuis sa
période en allemagne de l'est depuis sa
période à leningrad saint-pétersbourg et
ce sont des gens qu'on retrouve
aujourd'hui à des postes clés dans les
banques dans l'énergie dans les minerais
dans les métaux dans l'import export et
navalni les accusent de corruption et la
façon dont ils se sont enrichis
évidemment alors que en ce moment en
russie il ya quand même une crise
économique est en partie liée à la
pandémie
le niveau de vie de tous les russes
baisse pas de tous mais la majorité
il voit les effets les révélateurs de la
crise du coronavirus sur le système de
santé qui tient relativement bien à
moscou et dans les grandes villes mais
qui est complètement explosé dans l'est
dans les régions et donc ça provoque un
effet un effet dévastateur je pense
genre à gagner vous dit qu'on avait déjà
vu ces photos qui a eu des articles y
compris dans les médias russes
oui bien sûr bien sûr il y avait eu
quelques photos parce que il semble que
à l'époque
s'il ya une dizaine d'années il ya des
travailleurs qui travaillaient sur ce
chantier à l'intérieur qui avait fait
quelques photos et il ya des
journalistes qui ont réussi à les
acheter ou enfin ils ont trouvé plutôt
bien pour arrondir leurs salaires sans
doute de les vendre et donc ça avait
circulé et il y avait des questions qui
étaient posées à qui ça appartient et à
ce moment là il a été dit que ce ch ce
palais en construction avait été
revendue à un petit oligarques disons et
que c'était sa propriété
en fait les péripéties vont continuer je
vais pas faire jouer à vous faire le
film n'avait ni pour savoir que c'était
bien réussi les gens intéressés peuvent
l'aider frédéric pons mouly a joué les
choses et puis je donnerai la parole
arnaud dubien oui alors on dit lassé ces
jours derniers que en fait il y à des
travaux en ce moment et que ce très gros
bâtiment un peu kitsch en tout cas par
la décoration qu'on a pu voir ce sera un
hôtel de luxe à vérifier on verra dans
quelques temps mais cette enquête de
naval y est très très bien fait c'est
remarquable même si ils recyclent
beaucoup d'éléments connus mais une
enquête comme ça dans un média français
je vois pas qui pourrait la sortir parce
que c'est bourré de conditionnel de
suppositions et même si le montage est
très professionnel très remarquable
passionnant à suivre
eh bien on reste un peu sur sa faim
parce que on ne sait pas au final après
les deux heures de sujets à qui
appartient réellement
ce palais et on ne voit pas ce que
navalni apporte de nouveau si ce n'est
l'accusation extrêmement graves qui
pourraient être diffamatoires de
l'appartenance à vladimir poutine est en
réalité à travers ce document qui a été
parfaitement préparée montée pour le
retour de navalni en russie pour son
incarcération
c'est une élément de plus dans la
campagne anti poutine que mène navalni
depuis des années avec l'appui le
support d'un certain nombre d'amis en
russie certainement puisqu'il est
informé de l'intérieur mais aussi avec
l'appui de deux ong d'associations de
groupes qui sont clairement sur un front
anti poutine avec des moyens très
importants et la plupart viennent des
états unis et d'allemagne en eau du bien
oui je suis assez d'accord avec ce qu'il
en est de 10 alors ceci dit un un
oligarque à revendiquer la propriété de
du bâtiment ces derniers jours monsieur
rotenberg qui est par ailleurs le
constructeur du pont reliant le sud de
la russie à la crimée pour le reste oui
ce qu'on voit c'est que en réalité ce
palais n'est pas terminée et donc il est
douteux que poutine n'y ai jamais mis
les pieds est encore en tout cas
bon d'accord sur les la violence
des manifestations et
il y aurait eu plus de 5300 arrestation
et
deux manifestants depuis que ces
manifestations ont commencé et on dit
que là aussi c'est unique
depuis depuis le depuis 20 ans et depuis
enfin depuis la russie post soviétique
on va dire il n'y avait jamais eu autant
d'arrestations alors qu'en est il
exactement jean radvanyi oui je crois
qu'effectivement fin d'après tous les
médias russes ils disent qu'il ya eu un
record du nombre d'arrestations
il y en avait eu 4500 le 23 janvier il y
en a eu plus de 5000 cette fois ci ce
qui est inquiétant c'est bon c'est enfin
c'est de bonne guerre il sellal sellal
et l'application de la législation russe
les manifestations non autorisées
puisqu'elle n'était pas autorisée eh
bien on arrête ainsi nombre de gens en
plus ya effectivement des provocateurs
il ya eu aussi des cas constatés avérée
de violences policières
mais ce qui est ce qui est inquiétant
c'est à mon avis c'est pas tout à fait
ça c'est que le pouvoir est dans une
sorte d'impasse parce que il ne sait pas
comment discuter avec une partie de la
société
alors évidemment il ya l'argument que
c'est cesser ces gens sont tous
manipulés de l'étranger mais personne
n'y croit qui est des manipulateurs qui
aidé des interventions de dettes à tel
ou tel
on appelle ça de soual soft power soit
les agences évidemment qu'ils sont les
agences étrangères les allemands les par
les alpha les allemands les des
américains sont intéressés pour suivre
et éventuellement déstabiliser un
un fait un concurrent qui quand même
bien affaibli mais c'est pas c'est quand
c'est pas ça qui est personne n'y croit
parce que c'est bien clair que on a là
des problèmes intérieurs préoccupant est
que pour l'instant le pouvoir ne sait
pas répondre autrement que par des
mesures législatives de plus en plus
contraignantes dans tout un tas de
domaines je pense qu'on va y revenir
il y là il ya un nombre de lois
extraordinairement autoritaire et qui en
renforce les la surveillance de la
société de toute opposition qui ont été
votées fin décembre dans les derniers
jours de décembre 2020 tout à fait
étonnante et d'autre part cette
répression
d'ailleurs refusé toute autorisation de
manifestation il ya il ya des experts
russes que je viens de j'ai lu ça
aujourd'hui qu'ils disent mais enfin si
on avait autorisé cette manifestation il
y aurait eu quelques dizaines de
milliers de manifestants ils se seraient
ils auraient eu froid ils seraient
restés sur place et puis seraient
dispersés et probablement on en aurait
moins parler alors peut-être que c'est
un point de vue un peu naïf mais enfin
voilà pour l'instant ce que je constate
c'est que le pouvoir actuel ne sais pas
comment parler avec une partie de la
population qui est une partie jeunes
actives assez déterminé parce que pour
sortir manifester dans ces conditions il
faut être prédéterminée et et à terme ça
risque de poser quand même des problèmes
importants arnaud dubien sur ces
manifestations les arrestations et l'ue
telle usage de la force qui serait là
aussi disproportionnée at on dit oui je
crois que le pouvoir effectivement
récoltes dans une large mesure ce qu'il
a semé dans le sens où depuis une
dizaine d'années mais singulièrement
depuis 2002 on voit des serrage de vis
successifs on voit que les institutions
sont vidés de leur substance le
parlement les partis je ne parle
évidemment pas des grands médias d'état
et donc on évacue les problèmes
et on essaie de ne pas les remarquer on
est tous dans une large mesure une
position raisonnable et au demeurant
parfaitement minoritaires et ça provoque
des poussées ailleurs et des poussées
d'une opposition dite hors système par
définition moins contrôlable avec les
ingrédients qui ont été évoqués un
phénomène générationnel des gens qui
sont lassés du pouvoir de vladimir
poutine de cette génération une
génération qui n'a pas connu l'union
soviétique et qui donc est moins
sensible aux mises en garde sur les
années 90 ou qui ne sont pas ne sont pas
affectés par le traumatisme que peut
constituer que constitue certainement
pour la dîmière poutine et sa génération
l'effondrement de l'urss donc il ya un
décalage et à pouvoir effectivement qui
se contentent de serrer les vis de
réprimer sans proposer d'alternative en
tout cas sans laisser s'exprimer de
façon raisonnable et de façon canaliser
dans le cadre de la constitution
des idées qui par ailleurs sont je pense
minoritaire et ne remettent pas en cause
le pouvoir actuel donc c'est une c'est
une erreur stratégique qui a
effectivement conduit à une impasse
dans un contexte où les dirigeants sont
nerveux nerveux parce qu'il ya des
échéances on a dit parce qu'il ya un
contexte économique qui s'il n'est pas
catastrophique n'est pas bon et des
puissances étrangères notamment les
états unis de l'administration by donne
qui sont à l'affût et qui vont
certainement essayer de se saisir des
événements récents pour promouvoir sans
doute des sanctions fallait y pense on a
juste une minute et lumière dans la
porte
je suis assez d'accord oui sur sur ce
qui a été dit sur la fin de ce qui a été
dit c'est à dire les difficultés du
pouvoir à faire face à ce type
d'opposition
or system mais sur l'aspect maintien de
l'ordre une remarque quand même on voit
bien que le pouvoir a choisi de saturer
en forces de l'ordre ces manifestations
doux c'est très très nombreuses
arrestations
mais si l'on observe bien ce qui s'est
passé
il ya eu finalement peu ou assez peu de
violence policière j'ai regardé
énormément de reportages sur la
répression de ces manifestations dans
toute la russie
croyez moi c'était beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup moins violent que la répression
des manifestations des gilet jaune
en france on ne voit pas de blessé
quasiment pas ou en tout cas
l'opposition ne les a pas montré on voit
des gens emmené manu militari avec une
certaine fermeté c'est vrai mais sans
violence excessive me semble-t-il en
tout cas je n'ai pas vu ces images et au
final cette répression qui a été massive
parce qu'il y avait beaucoup de forces
de l'ordre s'est plutôt bien déroulé
pour le pouvoir
cela dit ça ne veut pas dire que et bien
les choses sont calmés pour autant et là
je rejoins nos deux débatteurs sur les
difficultés de l'administration actuelle
du pouvoir actuel de gérer tout ça ils
n'ont plus manifestement de de contact
sous suffisamment de contacts dans ces
nouvelles générations pour les
comprendre pour essayer peut-être de les
retourner de façon machiavélique et tous
les pouvoirs le font mais ils n'en n'ont
pas les moyens et à l'heure actuelle le
pouvoir répond par un juridisme
électorale un juridisme policiers pour
neutraliser tout avec l'objectif de
mettre navalni clairement en prison à
l'ombre en tout cas avant les les
élections législatives qui arrive on
fait une pause on se retrouve juste
après
[Musique]
les prévisions de croissance pour
l'année 2000 21 auront jamais été aussi
incertaine bien sûr que vous pouvez
avoir 6% à ce moment là mettez sur la
table comme le font les états unis 2000
milliards et puis vous aurez de la
croissance simplement il faudra les
rembourser un jour une fois qu'on sera
dans la période dément l'atterrissage
d'une soeur à ce moment là il y aura un
certain nombre de dispositifs qui
commenceront à tomber
c'est là que l'on pourra faire l état
des dégâts je vous rappelle que ça n'est
pas le virus qui tue l'économie ce sont
les mesures qu'on a appliqué pour
bloquer l'économie objectivement
personne ne sait ce que sera la
croissance de la france mais aussi de la
plupart des pays européens on peut
simuler une croissance mais une vraie
croissance qui repose sur des
fondamentaux solides
vous n'êtes pas prêt de la voir
un certain lien de confiance est rompu
entre le politique et les experts et
même les citoyens on est une société qui
est totalement a percuté et on ne peut
pas considérer une démocratie vit
véritablement l'amplitude de ses
possibles et l'amplitude de ses valeurs
quand elle est à ce point confiné est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment on repart à
zéro par rapport à l'année dernière
la société ne survivra pas à une
succession de confinement une société
c'est pas le confinement
c'est la liberté c'est la créativité
c'est le sentiment d'exister
d'appartenir
comment on va réorganiser le monde vivre
avec la pandémie c'est vivre
[Musique]
donc prenons cette émission avec
frédéric pons avec jean radvanyi et avec
arnaud dubien le directeur de
l'observatoire franco russe qui est qui
est exactement alexeï navalni puisque
vous venez de dire jean radvanyi qu'il
est devenu l'opposant numéro un ce qu'il
n'était peut-être pas avant avant tout
cela kitty long on le connaît mal ici
comment est il que veut-il et qui
représente t-il pour vous c'est un jeune
avocat brillant très qui a travaillé
dans des tas dans des domaines assez
divers y compris dans les affaires et du
coup il a un procès suspendu comme
avocat d'affaires
il a été aussi il a eu à l'autre tout à
l'heure ça a été dit il a eu une
trajectoire politique assez assez divers
c'est assez compliqué et il a été un
moment donné très proche des milieux
nationalistes plus difficiles en russie
on est toujours on hésite toujours à
qualifier certains mouvements de droite
ou de gauche parce que c'est pas très
claire la classification n'est pas
forcément la même qu'en france moi je
dirais plutôt de droite mais est très
très très très comment dire
il a beaucoup d'imagination et il a
trouvé un moyen tout à fait pertinent de
d'attaquer le système politique de
vladimir poutine par ces phénomènes de
corruption mais d'une façon extrêmement
concrètes
c'est à dire en cherchant dans le détail
des en montant des dossiers détaillants
des phénomènes de corruption concret sur
des entreprises sur des régions sur des
hommes il avait fait en particulier un
dossier alors après on peut en penser ce
qu'on veut sur le contenu mais
extrêmement étonnant et assez explosive
sur dmitri medvedev qui est qui avait
été président qui était premier ministre
donc très imaginatif et il a créé autour
de lui
non pas un parti mais un mouvement avec
des
des filiales dans beaucoup de régions de
russie avec des gens qui se retrouvent
dans cette personnalité c'est à dire
imagination nouvelles technologies les
réseaux sociaux des jeunes et qui
cherche partout et qui trouve
naturellement parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses qu'on peut trouver si on cherche
vraiment et si on a des aides il ya des
gens qui les aident et donc ils sont
devenus de ce point de vue là populaire
et en même temps c'est vrai frédéric
pons à raison qu' il n'est pas estimé
comme homme politique qui ne représente
pas l'opposition
c'est un homme d'opposition mais qui
n'est pas populaire et les sondages lui
donnent entre 2 5% et donc alors on la
laissait quand même se présenter aux
élections à moscou et là il a rassemblé
pourcentage significatif donc c'est pour
ça qu'ils représentent un danger parce
que si pour l'instant il n'est pas
effectivement l'homme le plus populaire
dans l'opposition il a un potentiel un
peu explosif anneaux du bien oui un
potentiel explosif
c'est un leader charismatique c'était un
leader qui a choisi des angles d'attaqué
pertinents qui peuvent porter il ya la
question de la corruption qui était
évoqué la question également du
nationalisme ruche navalni par exemple
ne s'est pas opposée annexion de la
crimée il faut le savoir
navalni 7 quelqu'un qui dénonce c'est
quelque part un un populiste c'est
quelqu'un qui est jusqu'à présent en
tout cas n'a pas proposé d'alternative
d'où la limite de son exercice n'est
mais encore une fois je ne crois pas que
contrairement à ce qui a pu être dit
poutine aient peur et n'avait que le
pouvoir ait peur de navalni parce qu'il
ne représente pas une menace immédiate
en revanche ce qui perturbe le système
ce à quoi un système n'est pas habitué
c'est que navalni n'a pas peur de
poutine et du crâne ça c'est quelque
chose qui les désarçonne et si on ajoute
évidemment l'utilisation des nouvelles
technologies des réseaux sociaux
le fait que navalni ses partisans
feuilles tonnes là les révélations tout
cela aboutit à une situation dans
laquelle le pouvoir est en retard il
réagi un scénario qu'il ne maîtrise pas
or la hantise plutôt la l'obsession du
pouvoir russe ira maîtrise des choses et
là il
il ne maîtrise pas le calendrier ne
maîtrise pas l'ensemble des facteurs ici
en france et en occident en général on
pense qu'il n'y a aucun doute que c'est
c'est le kremlin ou les services secrets
russes qui ont décidé de qui ont tenté
d'empoisonner navel ni qu'est ce que
vous en pensez frédéric pons
écoutez moi je n'ai aucun élément à la
différence de beaucoup de mes confrères
qui assure des choses sans avoir de
preuves on sait une chose c'est que
manifestement il a été empoisonnée alors
après de là à dire que ce sont les
services russes l'ordre de directe de
vladimir poutine
il ya un pas immense à franchir navalni
en s'attaquant à la corruption s'est
attaqué à vladimir poutine
mais à beaucoup d'autres réseaux en
russie des réseaux liés à la corruption
à grande échelle qui règne aussi dans ce
pays du caucase a à saint pétersbourg
donc il ya beaucoup de gens qui avaient
intérêts ou qui ont en permanence
intérêt à éliminer ce dénonciateur de
corruption pour l'instant moi je ne peux
pas affirmer je ne l'écrirai pas que
c'est vladimir poutine le responsable
direct et alors on dit mais c'est un
poison d'origine militaire russe le
fameux nos vies de choc
oui évidemment mais c'est tellement
signé ça a été tellement maladroit que
je n'arrive pas à croire ou alors je me
fais une toute autre idée de ce que sont
les services russes
j'arrive pas à croire que ce soit eux
c'est ces pieds nickelés ces charlots
qui ont monté cette opération qui a
lamentablement échoué et qui fait
ressortir 5 6 mois après navalni paix
tant la forme et défiant à nouveau la
lumière poutine
navalni est très fort je partage ce qui
a été dit mais je voudrais rajouter
quelque chose et il a la force
de sa jeunesse il est intelligent il est
beau il est il à la force que lui
apporte sa femme son épouse aussi il
sait jouer des réseaux sociaux il est
charismatique il séduit et il a aussi
une force qui est un peu une faiblesse
vis-à-vis du rpt du pouvoir russe il a
été formé aux états unis en partie il a
séjourné à l'université de yale où il a
reçu un enseignement pour la défense de
la démocratie
il a le soutien de fondations
occidentale de fondation dédiée à la
défense des droits de l'homme et de la
démocratie est donc sacré dit pour le
kremlin mais aussi pour beaucoup de
russes et des russes me l'ont dit des
russes à à moscou sa grille dit l'idée
qu' il n'est peut-être pas tout à fait
libre qu'il est peut-être dans la main
peut-être dans la main de réseaux
d'influencé occidentaux navali à une
faiblesse c'est que il apparaît il ya
encore il ya une dizaine d'années dans
le débat politique
et c'est vrai et je le redis il est
passé de la droite à la gauche de la
droite et de la gauche à la droite avec
un positionnement nationaliste que ne
renierait aucun populistes en europe de
l'ouest
on peut dire aujourd'hui que la vanille
est une sorte de populiste high tech de
techno populiste avec le la science des
réseaux sociaux avec la force que lui
donnent ses convictions et il avance
brutalement souvent par la caricature et
c'est ce qui c'est ce qui fait une part
de son succès comme on a on observe en
europe occidentale le succès de certains
populistes qui ont des formules à
l'emporte-pièce et qui sont devenus des
maîtres en matière d'utilisation des
réseaux sociaux
navalni est un peu ça avec des idées
parfois extrêmement nationaliste qui
étonnerait beaucoup de confrères ici en
france qui le voient comme un parangon
de la défense des droits de l'homme et
et de la démocratie à l'américaine
jean radvanyi sur l'empoisonnement de
n'avait ni au jeu
il ya un nombre de points obscurs c'est
clair que admettons que ceux produits
viennent de ces deux de ces sources
russes le bleu prodanovic le fameux nos
vies de choc
étant donné ce qu'est la corruption en
russie il n'y a pas qu'une seule
personne la demi-heure poutine qui a
accès et j'imagine effectivement qu'on
sait c'est une des hypothèses c'est que
d'autres d'autres que ce soit des
oligarques où que ce soit des lobbys ou
que ce soit des gens qui ont
effectivement été attaqué par les
enquêtes de navalni qu'ils puissent
trouver le moyen d'accéder à ce produit
et de de faire en sorte que telle ou
telle équipe alors parce que la vanne il
a sorti un autre film entre temps il a
fait cette interview incroyable les
responsables du fsb se faisant passer
pour quelqu'un d'autre et qui lui donne
à ce nombre d'éléments sur ce qui se
serait passé
moi je mets tout au conditionnel su
comme feuilles posées par les éléments
alors les russes des russes disent autre
chose il accuse les allemands de ne pas
fournir le dossier médical de navalni là
dessus non plus je n'ai pas d'éléments
donc peut-être qu'on aura des éléments
supplémentaires pour l'instant voilà il
ya ces accusations elles sont graves lui
a décidé d'accuser frontalement l'a dit
mi-août it
mais ça fait partie de son de sa
stratégie évidemment et ça attire
l'attention d'autant plus après il va y
avoir sans doute des sanctions on va en
parler à nos du bien pour vous l'a dit
mir poutine aurait eu un intérêt à
vouloir éliminer
navalni on peut avoir des convictions
aucune certitude personnellement je ne
crois pas à l'hypothèse d'un ordre
explicite de vladimir poutine pour
éliminer l'excès navalni
en revanche je trouve que les
révélations qui ont été faites au mois
de décembre par saddam médias
occidentaux
quant à l'implication de certains agents
russes me paraissent crédibles et on
peut parfaitement imaginer c'est pas
beaucoup plus rassurant d'ailleurs que
certaines unités de services russes
s'engagent dans des opérations
d'élimination sans ordre du chef de
l'état et est alors pour quelle raison
est ce que alexeï navalni est revenu en
russie alors qu'il savait qu'il serait
qu'ils seraient arrêtés que vous avez
l'air de dire tous les trois qu'il
risque de passer assez longtemps en
prison en tout cas qu'il ne pourra pas
espérer se présenter aux prochaines
élections auxquelles quel est son
intérêt là est ce qu'il n'aurait pas
mieux fait de rester en occident
justement
boîtier rentrer en russie frédéric pons
tout simplement parce que la légitimité
de son combat politique c'est de se
trouver en russie précisément russie il
a observé ce que sont devenus les
opposants qui ont choisi l'exil et qui
ont essayé de monter en exil des
mouvements d'opposition à vladimir
poutine
ils sont quasiment tous oublié en tout
cas il ne pèse absolument rien ils
savaient qu'en rentrant en russie
il risquait énormément et en cela il
faut reconnaître son courage et celui de
son épouse mais à l'extérieur du pays il
n'existait plus ils allaient être oublié
balayé or là en revenant russie c'est
vrai qu'il va en prison il va y rester
plusieurs mois peut-être plusieurs
années mais en même temps il fait
fermenter cette opposition qui l'a fait
naître notamment chez les jeunes ce dont
on parlait tout à l'heure ses grandes
manifestations dans toute la russie
signifie que là quelque chose a pris le
ferment fonctionne et c'est en étant sur
place en étant un martyr en se jetant
dans la gueule du loup où la gueule de
l'ours que il a toute sa légitimité que
son combat peut effectivement continuer
votre avis genre à venir parce qu'on se
dit après tout et pourquoi l'avoir
arrêté aussi comme on se pose la
question pourquoi l'avoir en prison
empoisonné
cc c'est véritablement vouloir se se
noircir aux yeux à la fois de l'occident
mais du peuple russe aussi alors
pourquoi l'avoir empoisonnée il ya déjà
eu des réponses parce que il ya eu un
certain nombre de gens qui sont morts
nemtsov un ancien premier ministre
des journalistes politkovskaïa et
d'autre et la réponse de la dîmière
poutine s'était met enfin à quoi
à quoi bon il était insignifiant il ne
jouait pas drôle pourquoi voulez vous
qu'on cherche
allez allez détruire la raison pourquoi
on l'arrête c'est différent là je pense
que je pense que c'est une erreur en
fait politique mais qui était inévitable
dessus suivant ce que ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure c'est clair que le
pouvoir n'a pas trouvé le moyen de
donner une place à cette opposition
dérangeante évidemment très minoritaire
pas très populaire pour l'instant si on
regarde les sondages mais qui qui existe
et au lieu de lui des d'essayer de lui
trouver une place
la seule réponse du pouvoir c'est la
coercition et donc on l'arrête on
l'arrête parce que sinon on ne sait pas
très bien quoi faire
or en l'arrêtant bien sûr on en fait un
martyr et en cristallise sur sa
personnalité
toute une série de couches et et en plus
on ouvre un
une porte pour de nouvelles sanctions
occidentales
alors on sait que les sanctions
précédentes n'ont pas n'ont pas fait
fléchir la demi-heure poutine n'ont pas
considérablement entravé l'économie
russe mais elle pose des problèmes
et effectivement je ne sais pas si on va
en parler de ce fameux gazoduc north
stream 2 ça fait partie des sanctions
possibles et il ya des grands projets
qui peuvent être arrêtés ce qui posera
des problèmes aux russes et aux
européens d'ailleurs parce que c'est
probablement les américains qui vont
lancer ses nouvelles sanctions anneux du
bien oui il paraît évident que le
pouvoir russe aurait préféré que leurs
ennemis restent en allemagne ne rentre
pas effectivement il n'est pas vraiment
d'autre choix que de l'interpeller de
l'incarcérer à son arrivée je crois que
les règles du jeu ont un peu changé si
j'ose dire pendant longtemps navalni a
été perçu par le pouvoir comme un
élément perturbateur comme il pouvoir
jouer un peu au chat et à la souris avec
lui il est clair que depuis l'automne
depuis la tentative d'empoisonnement
d'où qu'elles viennent
neil valmy est devenu un ennemi il sera
traité comme tel donc le laisser
poursuivre sur l'activité politique en
russie elles seules scénario exclu les
autres étant la prison où l'exil est ce
que ça veut dire qu'on n'a pas le droit
d'être and opposants en russie il ya des
lignes rouges
il y a des codes il y à des sujets
tabous il ya des oppositions
parlementaires en russie le parti
communiste est passé maître dans l'art
de nous voyez connais très bien les
lignes rouges
le parti communiste attaque les
oligarques mais n'attaque pas poutine
n'attaque pas la politique étrangère
de vladimir poutine donc voilà il y à
des oppositions que certains
qualifieront docile mais qui accepte les
règles du jeu telles qu'elles ont été
établies depuis une dizaine d'années une
quinzaine d'années m
alexeï navalni s'inscrit hors de ce
système là et il le pouvoir cela a été
dit qu'ils savaient coopté le pouvoir
russe au début de la présidence poutine
qui n'est pas linéaire il ya eu
plusieurs poutine finalement au début
des années 2000 le pouvoir russe savez
faire preuve d'une certaine souplesse
savez coopté certains de ses opposants
et de ce point de vue là il est assez
amusant si j'ose dire que l'une des
personnes sanctionnées à l'automne
dernier au titre de la sphère d'un bel
niçois par exemple monsieur kirienko
ancien premier ministre de boris eltsine
figure éminente de la mouvance libérale
et grand ami de boris nemtsov
réponse oui je crois que l'on peut
reprocher bien sûr beaucoup de choses à
côté mais il faut lui reconnaître une
qualité c'est le pragmatisme le réalisme
politique
poutine est un politique un homme
politique est comme tous les politiques
que ce soit en russie comme en occident
il regarde les sondages et entre
plusieurs mauvaises solutions
il a dû en choisir une et je pense qu'il
a aussi regardé les sondages pour
décider quoi faire de ce navalni 7,7
mouche ce frelon agaçant qui revenait en
russie eh bien les sondages y compris ce
fait parler les instituts de sondages
les plus respectables en tout cas les
plus reconnus selon nos critères en
occident les sondages fond plafonné
navalni en termes de popularité ou de
crédibilité à 2 3 4 % sable ça va monter
peut-être un peu avec ce qui s'est passé
ce retour mouvementé mais en terme de
popularité de crédibilité il est très
très bas
ça ne veut pas dire qu'en cas d'élection
à moscou à saint pétersbourg ou au coeur
de certaines grandes villes il n'aurait
pas quelques succès on l'a vu à moscou
où il avait atteint je crois 30% alors
d'une municipale à moscou mais au niveau
national il reste extrêmement bas
c'est ce que disent de façon constante
les sondages et entre deux maux et bien
poutine et ses conseillers ont choisi
sans doute le moindre c'est à dire
d'encaisser une petite tempête mais de
le mettre à l'ombre quelques temps le
temps peut-être de le faire oublier en
tout cas qu'il ne gêne pas le jeu
politique traditionnel notamment
l'opposition traditionnelle
ce qui vient d'être dit dans la
perspective des élections législatives
de l'automne
jean radvanyi qu'est ce qui risque de se
passer maintenant d'après vous on peut
on peut penser qu'effectivement navalni
va rester en prison au moins jusqu'à
l'automne puisque les élections
législatives vont venir
il peut y avoir quelques récidive de
manifestations en fait le je pense que
les problèmes vont se déplacer les
problèmes vont se déplacer parce qu'il
faut quand même se souvenir que on est
dans une période de pandémie que la
situation du virus alors il ya des il ya
des signaux contradictoires
il ya un petit allègements sur moscou
mais là le virus est encore très actif
dans toute la russie
c'est préoccupant dans beaucoup de
régions où le système médical s'est
effondré ne peux pas répondre et donc il
ya beaucoup de morts après de nous après
beaucoup d'hésitations le pouvoir a dû
reconnaître que les chiffres qu'il avait
donné de mort par pendaison russes sont
faux c'est assez étonnant parce que
l'avenir poutine a continué de dire non
non nous sommes parmi les pays qui ont
nui le mieux résisté or le gosse comme
ce tacle le l'institut des statistiques
a révélé comme il le fait tout le temps
heureusement on est plus à la perte de
brejnev fou quand un chiffre génère on
le supprimait là ils ont publié le
nombre de morts dans toute la russie
pratiquement sur l'année 2020 et on
s'aperçoit que il ya une surmortalité
très importante et on sait ils ont
reconnu qu'une bonne partie de ces
surmortalités c'était la vraie mortalité
les vrais chiffres de mortalité du virus
dont il ya ça qui est pas réglé et puis
il ya la situation économique qui n'est
pas catastrophique comme à diar dont du
bien
qui est préoccupante parce que
effondrement des investissements
étrangers
alors on verra c'est peut-être
conjoncturel on est quand même dans une
situation mondiale très particulière
effondrement du niveau de vie un
effondrement baisse du niveau de vie
baisse des revenus
il ya beaucoup de russes on n'a pas les
réseaux de protection que qu'on a en
france
il ya beaucoup de russes qui étaient qui
était payé en entier ou en partie au
noir ou par différentes façons du coup
ils ont perdu tout ça il ya eu il ya
quelques années il n'y a pas eu de
politique sociale alors peut-être qu'il
va le faire pour les élections à venir
c'est à dire il n'y a pas eu de relance
importante au niveau des aides sociales
pour les catégories qui sont touchés par
cette crise donc on a on a un contexte
économique et politique et démographique
qui s'est durci et qui va avoir des
conséquences et c'est ça qui va jouer
peut-être davantage alors est-ce que
navalni va être capable ou son mouvement
de passer de cette dénonciation de la
corruption a une démarche un peu plus
actives sur ces sujets là pour l'instant
il ne l'a pas fait et c'est pas sûr
qu'il puisse le faire mais il ya
peut-être d'autres partis qui vont
essayer d'en profiter un petit peu
arnaud dubien oui effectivement la
situation socio économique c'est un mot
nazi le le facteur à suivre il faut se
garder de l'image d'une économie russe
qui se seraient effondrés dont la russie
s'en tire plutôt bien en réalité
en 2020 avec une récession qui sera
limitée à 3%
si on compare aux 8% de la france on
voit que c'est plus bien mieux mais
cela a été dit cela ne nous laisse pas
les problèmes récurrents que sont les
inégalités sociales ça c'est quelque
chose et les inégalités de revenus c'est
quelque chose qui est très visible qui
est très mal acceptée en russie de ce
point de vue là il ya une vraie
similitudes entre lire et les mentalités
françaises et russes
et de ce point de vue là ce que dit la
vanille mais ce que disent aussi les
communistes et d'autres sur l'oligarchie
ça peut porter il y à il ya eu il faut
s'en souvenir et c'est pour ça que mon
avis poutine parvient à se maintenir
encore de façon très très réel dans les
sondages il y a eu une décennie dorée en
russie entre 1999 et 2008 il ya eu 7 %
croissance des revenus qui a été
multiplié par dix le problème c'est que
depuis il ya une décennie perdue avec
une stagnation une croissance limitée 1%
ce qui est un peu plus inquiétant est ce
qui explique en partie à mon avis la
mobilisation que l'on voit ces derniers
jours l'absence d'ascenseur sociaux qui
étaient bien réelles au cours des années
2000 donc il est plus une lassitude ce
qui a été dit donc quelque chose qui
n'est pas explosif qui est plutôt de
l'ordre du moyen terme de la fatigue
mais qui pourrait pourquoi pas à
l'automne à l'occasion de la sortie de
crise justement à s'exprimer de façon un
peu plus visible
y compris au coeur des lecteurs
accouting ses retraités
les employés du secteur public qui qui
ont plutôt bénéficié encore une fois des
politiques publiques jusqu'à présent
mais qui aujourd'hui sont un peu plus
exposés c'est très paradoxal parce que
l'état russe est riche les caisses de
l'état russe n'ont jamais été aussi
pleine l'état russe n'a que 20 % de la
dette publique
donc il a les moyens théoriquement de
distribuer de l'argent ce qu'il ne fait
pas alors peut-être qu'il va le faire à
la proche des élections il ya des marges
de manoeuvre dont paradoxalement ne
s'est pas vraiment servi jusqu'à présent
et il pense oui alors j'ajoute une chose
et je crois et arnaud dubien le sait le
sait je crois aussi enfin le fmi vient
de sortir des des prévisions de
croissance pour la russie qui sont sur
2021 et 2022
2 3% et où un peu plus ce qui ferait
envie à beaucoup de pays de la vieille
europe
je voudrais dire que pour comprendre
cette affaire navalni en fait il faut
sortir la russie parce que cette affaire
n'a valley est une affaire à plusieurs
étages
le premier étage navalni son retour en
russie a été allumé il fallait mobiliser
en russie agacé déstabiliser faire
douter peut-être une partie de
l'establishement politique russe ça
c'est le premier étage mais le deuxième
étage est en train d'être allumé c'est
l'état qui est allumée de l'extérieur et
c'est peut-être ça qu'il ya derrière
cette affaire navalni parce que on situe
cette affaire dans le cadre de relations
internationales extrêmement compétitives
entre la russie et l'europe et les états
unis
et bien ce deuxième étage c'est à la
fois le dossier des sanctions et le
dossier de ce fameux gazoduc north
stream 2002 130 km sous la baltique de
la russie à l'allemagne
les américains en ont fait un casus
belli avec l'europe
ils ont dit très clairement et joe biden
l'a dit ce gazoduc est une très mauvaise
affaire pour l'europe
ça veut dire aussi pour les états unis
il n'est pas question qu'il soit qu'il
aille au bout ce chantier est donc le
deuxième étage de cette fusée navalni
c'est cette pression qui va redoubler
sur les pays européens pour stopper gelé
dégradé ce projet de gazoduc et pour
entretenir encore pendant des mois et
des mois ces fameuses sanction est
derrière tout ça il ya les intérêts
américains
les intérêts du gaz américain qu'ils
veulent livrer à l'europe à partir de la
croatie
et puis les intérêts commerciaux de
l'amérique qui tout en imposant des
sanctions à la russie et en demandant à
l'europe de faire respecter ces
sanctions et bien continuent de
commercer les américains continuent de
commercer avec la russie malgré les
sanctions et nous européens nous sommes
de bons élèves
nous appliquons ces sanctions qui
pénalise une grande partie de notre
appareil agro-industriels et industriels
d'accord arnaud dubien il nous reste 40
secondes absolument je crois que l'une
des constantes de la politique
américaine depuis obama en réalité ces
deux devriez un découplage entre la
russie et le reste de l'europe la crise
ukrainienne de ce point de vue là était
du pain bénit on voit que dans ce
contexte les intérêts français en
particulier ont beaucoup souffert les
intérêts industriels agricoles et la
question de la souveraineté se pose très
directement à la lumière de ces
sanctions vous remercie tous les trois
d'avoir participé à cette émission
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]